clean beauty salon and spa offering a
variety of services and here to share
her expertise with us is the owner of
desert beauty lab susan salas susan
thank you for being here so much for
having us here and thank you for this
display i'm excited to learn a little
bit about what you guys do we have a few
demos planned but let's just talk about
desert beauty lab and what you guys
offer so we really focus on the natural
clean beauty no acrylics no fumes our
products are all organic certified so we
really focus on the experience with our
guests so we want to demo some therma
gun on you it's a deep tissue relaxation
that we can add on to your manicure and
pedicure services so nikki is our
manicurist and she'll be demoing you yes
i'm all about a massage
i was saying i have one of these at home
but i never know exactly how to properly
use it so you can get this done while
you're getting another service it's kind
of a two-for-one right exactly so while
you're getting a manicure and pedicure
services you can add this to your
service it's really a deep tissue
relaxation if anybody's sore with their
legs or workout this is a great way to
add on to your service
we also have our mindful meditation
manicure and pedicure where they can
really zone out
you don't need to talk to your nail
technician if you don't really want to
and be in the moment
we also have kai yes hi thank you for
being here as well we have another demo
plan this is just so fun i'm kind of sad
we had to stop the massage but let's
move on over here
i'm an aesthetician and also i'm a level
three reiki therapist okay so for the
welding
we start off
with the
chocolate cream i love it yeah it's good
for like mind and body healing reducing
the stress anxiety and overall for the
well-being
and we use that skincare product it's
all organic with the botanical power so
i'm gonna apply the serum on her okay
yes i've always heard of chakras and i
know there's so much to explore when it
comes to you know natural and clean and
just all of these different remedies
that can really do a lot for your
overall health and as ky over here is
doing her demo let's just talk about
some of the other facials and things
that you offer as well so we do a dbl
signature facial and this is a added on
service where you can really get into
the eminence organic line we use a light
therapy we do the hydro dermabrasion on
you so you really your skin feels full
relaxed and hydrated at the same time
also with that
we're gonna we're looking at the 20 22
new trends okay
we don't do acrylics on our salon we opt
out on powder and monomers
our next clean beauty is the
gel x system okay so with the gel x
there is no smell to it
and also with this is the 2022 french
look so everybody is going crazy with
the different colors in french you
really can get really creative in how
your design of french is
the more color the glitter the better it
is for 2022. well thank you yes if
you're heading into the new year this is
a great way to start clean start fresh
everyone go check out desert beauty lab
where can people find you we are located
in the south valley over on cimarron and
durango and you can also come to our wwe
desert beauty lab and book your
appointment there perfect